hey everybody welcome to another hd
tutorial in this one i'll be showing you
how to utilize the ccleaners registry
editor and cleaner tool i'm just going
to open up ccleaner for you now and if
you don't already have ccleaner um go
ahead and watch my video on how to get
it it is a freeware program and i really
do recommend it it's a really nice piece
of software now there is a new version
available but the same features do apply
to this older version version two so
here we go
go into the registry tab
and here we can see um basically it's
it's looking over your entire registry
and scanning it for issues missing or
shared dlls unused file extensions
unused fonts etc just things that you
don't need or that are jumbled up in
your registry that it has the
opportunity to remove so um let's go
ahead and scan for issues here
and i'll actually let this run for you
guys in real time it starts off very
slowly and then it finishes up quickly
after about 40 or 50 percent so it's
basically looking through almost the
entire windows registry and you can see
we already have a little bit of issues i
haven't run this in a while but a little
bit of issues with um maybe things that
i i've downloaded and never used maybe
missing file extensions
so here it's halfway done let's finish
and i'll actually go through through
these with you here it says completely
done one of these is an activex issue an
invalid defi default icon
and open with application issue and
another activex issue so in order to fix
these problems you can uncheck them and
show check the certain ones that you do
want to uh to fix or we can go to the
top and just check the the tab check the
button next to problem to select all we
had
fixed selected issues and you do have
the opportunity to back up changes to
the registry and i do recommend this if
you're making a large number of changes
however i do not need to do this for now
and basically you can go to the right
and left to see the different uh
descriptions of them so it says this
activex issue is often left behind after
excuse me after uninstalling software so
the solution is to delete the registry
value and it will tell you under every
single one
what the solution is
you can fix individual issues or you
could just hit fix all selected issues
and okay and bam that was fixed all four
issues were fixed we hit close
and your registry says no issues were
found
so there we go that's just one of the
quick little tools that i'll show you
guys and i'll go over a lot of new quick
little tools especially in like ccleaner
and camtasia studio 6 audacity i've got
a lot of tutorials again to do for you
guys but that's that's it for this one
so if you do have any tutorial ideas
um or requests or anything you'd like uh
to message me go ahead and subscribe and
message me through youtube and i'll try
to get uh the best request video and
then i can this one was not a request
but again i do take requests so thanks
for watching this one have a nice day
and subscribe peace